une première pierre en légaux posés
devant les travaux du nouveau bâtiment
du centre hospitalier de poissy saint
germain en laye la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé agnès buzyn
était présente lors de cet événement
symbolique autour d'elle de nombreuses
personnalités politiques gérard larcher
valérie pécresse pierre bédier ou encore
karl olive le projet de l'extension du
site finalise d'une certaine manière le
long processus de fusion engagée en 1997
entre les deux sites hospitaliers
aujourd'hui on est sur des conditions
d'accueil qui sont un petit peu
difficile par rapport aux standards
habituels et donc là le nouveau bâtiment
va permettre justement d'atteindre ses
standards objectif de ce projet
immobilier moderniser les modes de prise
en charge développer les coopérations
médical et assurer la mise aux normes de
certaines activités sanitaires
les plans prévoient un bâtiment de 19
mille mètres carrés sur six étages un
centre financé pour moitié par le
ministère et l'agencé régionale de santé
ars et l'autre moitié par
l'établissement
c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant avec la
rs pour pouvoir aujourd'hui avoir un
projet qui est bien est un périmètre de
70 millions d'euros à la fois sur pc
mais aussi sur saint germain en laye
avec une restructuration autour de
l'accueil de jour et des
hospitalisations qui soient plus tenus
pour cette première symbolique une
cinquantaine de manifestants étaient
réunis pour contester le projet si vous
n'avez pas de praticiens si vous n'avez
pas de personnel vous aurez toujours
autant de que halle aux urgences de
poissy puisqu'il arrive parfois d'avoir
des records datant de 7 8 9 10 heures
avant d'être soigné la dernière pierre
de ce nouveau bâtiment du centre
hospitalier poissy-saint-germain-en-laye
doit être posée en avril 2020